joining us right now is republican
congressman tony gonzalez his district
includes the city of uvalde texas
congressman good morning let's jump
right in you've been in touch with
officials there and last night you said
that there's still families waiting to
be connected with their children are
there still families um waiting to be
reunited
yeah good morning thank you for having
me you know it was such a horrific scene
that uh many of the children could not
be identified and they had to use dna
and other other avenues to identify
children so that's still ongoing i'll
get a briefing today at 10 30 there in
uvalde with all the latest details of it
along with governor abbott and senator
cornyn but imagine you're a parent and
you can't even identify your child so
this is what our community is dealing
with i am a parent i'm a father of six
and it hit me pretty hard yesterday and
you know as i was making my way my
district was very large as i was making
my way from el paso to the other side of
the district driving overnight yet
really let me process things and
not only do we have to think about the
victims we also have to think about the
survivors you know you mentioned you
know the board attack there were border
patrol agents these were the folks that
neutralized this shooter and ultimately
saved lives the stories i've heard where
there were there were a couple of
children that were hiding in a closet if
it wasn't for these agents uh you know
who knows what happened to those
children
i keep thinking about those children too
congressman the the children that didn't
survive and the ones that did
what they saw is something nobody should
see especially a little child but you
know you have voted against two gun gun
reform measures uh including one that
that called for expanded background
checks are you rethinking that position
this morning in light of what has
happened
in your in
happy to debate i'm happy to debate
policy uh not today i mean today we my
community is hurting you know
politicians like to divide us leaders
unite us and we need to be united right
now as americans because what happened
in uvalde texas can happen anywhere and
we have to be united in protecting our
children against that right now i've got
families that don't that can't identify
their children i've got folks that have
to bury their children i mean these are
the things that we're working with i'm
worried about the police officers that
came out of that scene covered in blood
that they have seen so much that they've
got to get pulled off of the front line
i'm worried about the community in
itself i'm happy to debate policy
another time but today we should be
united we should talk about the
survivors as well as well as the victims
i hear you loud and clear and i
certainly don't want to debate this and
i i too am thinking about the survivors
and the victims
but this is the issue this keeps
happening and we keep skirting around it
and we keep saying
somebody do something and nobody does
anything and we keep hearing it's the
second amendment rights the right to
bear arms and i keep thinking when the
founding fathers wrote that they were
talking about muskets i do not think if
if they were here today that they were
thinking that people kids would have
these assault rifles so if not now to
debate it if not not debate discuss it
right i just want to know you're in a
position but but with all due respect
you're in a position of power you're in
a position of power to change things
right and if we can't talk about it and
we can't make changes when can we talk
about it yeah to me this is a perfect
day to talk about you know i grew up in
camp wood texas you know very
30 40 miles from uvalde this is my home
you've audi isn't a dot on a map for me
it's not a political football for me
this is home these people i know these
are my community i represent them i love
them right now we need love we need
compassion we need people to come
together as we heal you ask what what
have we done and i'll give you we need
love but we need change congressman we
need change we need congress to come
together we need congress to come
together we need change
please
you've heard everybody say we don't need
the love and the prayers and the support
in the moment of silence they're saying
we're sick of that we don't need that
now i'm a man of faith my community is a
man
welcome your prayers let me let me give
an example of what we did last year so
the county judge who is a democrat the
mayor who is a republican and myself we
sat down over a year ago and you know
what we talked about we talked about
building a mental health clinic in
uvalde texas something that does not
exist and what did we do i used one of
my community projects and we allocated
two million dollars for this mental
health clinic it's a 20 million dollar
project i'm focused on how do i come up
with the other 18 million dollars if you
are a parent watching today i would say
reach out to your school find out what
your school's policies are find out what
mental health facilities are in your
area not only for your own family but
for others these are the things that
need that brings us together because
when tragedy hits
it doesn't determine if you're a
republican or democrat voted the club
right in who you pray to exactly this
country we need to come together dale
together not divide us
all of us need to come together and
focus on coming together though i think
is making change to keep the guns out of
people that should not be walking around
with
with and i don't want to take your guns
away from responsible gun owners nobody
wants to do that right but we've got to
go we've got to move people once full
safety but
just like every other father and mother
in america these are the conversations
that congress and others should be
having these conversations not the
division congress there's too much
division in this country yeah i agree
with you i agree with you and we thank
you tony gonzalez for taking the time to
spend time with us this morning